the world of mobular rays transcends the
barriers between oceans the borders
between shallow seas and cold ocean
depths and even the ocean's ultimate
barrier the one between sea and sky
found in tropical and temperate seas
around the world the genus mobula
contains some of the most incredible
organisms that have ever graced this
planet there are over 600 species of Ray
in the ocean but only 11 different
species of mobul array all of which have
a distinct diamond shaped appearance
with wings that allow them to glide
through the water and put on stunning
displays of Elegance and Agility some
are small and congregate in incredible
numbers occasionally flying out of the
water in acrobatic leaps others are
absolutely enormous so enormous that
their Elegance appears to defy gravity
the giant Oceanic mantay is is the
largest species of Reay in the world
with wingspans that can reach over 8 m
their sheer size makes them a striking
presence in the ocean captivating
researchers and divers who are lucky
enough to encounter them but more than
just being huge they're also gregarious
and often as curious about human
swimmers as the swimmers are of them and
this is because the giant Oceanic manay
is incredibly intelligent manay have the
largest brains of all fish with a
brain-to-body ratio that exceeds that of
the enormous whale shark and it turns
out giant manta rays are much more
mysterious than scientists even realized
until very recently we didn't even know
how to categorize them until 2018
scientists listed giant Manas and reef
manay under the genus Manta but more
analysis of their morphology and
genetics resulted in scientists placing
them in the mobula genus along with
smaller Devil Rays and now scientists
are learning that the giant Oceanic
manay isn't the animal they once thought
it was it's not simply a shallow water
Plankton eater but a deep sea Renegade
with movement so efficient that teams of
roboticists around the world are working
to emulate it and not only does it dive
deeper than we ever thought and move
more efficiently than we ever thought to
the shock of the Science World giant
manta ray have been observed to rapidly
change the color and pattern of their
skin something that's basically unheard
of in the world of elasmo branks the
giant ocean Manta is Big intelligent and
still absolutely full of mysteries why
did the giant ocean manta ray evolve to
become so enormous and how does an
enormous body move so efficiently what
are they doing when they dive to the
cold dark depths and what does it it
mean when they change their
color as the giant Oceanic manta ray
Glides through the water it flaps its
massive pectoral fins giving the
appearance that it's flying when Rays
diverged from sharks around 200 million
years ago the pectoral fins expanded
into what we now call the ray dis and
for the giant Oceanic manta ray this
expansion was extreme their wings can
reach over 8 m across and their pectoral
fins make up around 85% of their body
length for sharks of a similar size
their pectoral fins make up just 10 to
15% of their body length but what
benefit do such massive Wings give
versus the more typical sharkish body
plan a hint emerges by observing the
behavior of the giant manter Ray
compared to the similarly sized great
white shark the great white shark is a
powerful fast swimmer but its bursts of
speed usually only happen in One
Direction it's hard for a great white
shark to turn on a dime compare this to
the giant manta ray it's often seen
swimming in tight acrobatic circles
circling back to eat clusters of
Plankton or to evade Predators its
maneuverability and Agility are almost
unheard of in such large animals and
it's thanks to the giant manta's large
and flexible wings while the overall
shape of a man Wing is similar to the
wings of birds these fins can undulate
and bend in many more ways than bird
wings can the manay has numerous support
structures inside the pectoral Fin and
these structures can all be controlled
separately but as useful as
maneuverability is for evading Predators
it comes at a cost maneuverability is
simply controlled inability and without
stability an animal can't move steadily
and efficiently along a predictable path
luckily the giant Oceanic manta ray
strikes a balance between these opposing
qualities and is maneuverable while also
maintaining stability and efficiency one
way the giant manay maintains stability
is by having wings with a fairly High
aspect ratio during flight in the sea or
in the sky longer narrower Wings give a
plane or manay more stability it's sort
of like a tight RPP Walker who holds a
long pole as they walk the extra length
helps balance the body manay wings
aren't exactly long and skinny like
glider wings but their length does help
balance the animal while gliding High
aspect ratio Wings also help generate
lift efficiently and the way the giant
manta moves its pectoral fins also
allows its swimming to be highly
efficient and sometimes surprisingly
fast on average giant manta rays swim
about 9 mph or 14 1/ 12 km per hour hour
but to evade danger they can Sprint as
fast as 22 mph or 35.5
kmph to reach these speeds they combine
fin oscillations with
undulations oscillations are the
flapping of the wing up and down which
generates large propulsive and lift
forces but at the same time that the
wing is oscillating up and down it's
also undulating sending a traveling wave
outwards from its body towards its
flexible wing tips as giant rays flap in
this manner their fins disturb the water
and create vortices which push against
the surrounding water and propels the
animal forward and these two types of
motion make the giant manay an extremely
efficient swimmer scientists have
measured the propulsive efficiency to be
89% to understand more about the biology
of manta rays I talked with Jessica Pate
founder of the Florida Manta project and
research scientist at the the Marine
megap Foundation basically manta rays
have to keep swimming in order to
breathe so they are designed to swim
you'll never see one resting on the
bottom so they're just designed very
hydrodynamically efficient they have
like this more pointy diamond shaped
body structure where normally like a
stingray that lives on the bottom is
going to be just more like round so they
can get a lot more power out of their
wing tips it's so powerful and efficient
that researchers are designing
underwater autonomous vehicles modeled
after giant manes they hope that these
bioinspired machines will be able to
help map the sea floor perform search
and rescue missions and inspect
underwater technology far more nimbly
and efficiently than current systems
based on their pancake-like shape and
flapping wings you might assume that
mobulas are a bigger version of
stingrays it's true that all of them
belong to the elasmo bran subclass of
cartilagenous fish as do shark and
skates but there are some significant
differences between mobulas and
stingrays mobulas have mouths on the
front of their bodies rather than
underneath they also have calic loes
which are two fin-like appendages around
their mouths unlike the anterior part of
most stingrays these calic loes do not
have any electrosensory abilities rather
they're there to help funnel water and
Plankton straight into their mouths the
calic loes make mobular Rays the only
vertebrate with six paired appendages
rather than four two by their mouth two
pectoral fins that act as their wings
and two pelvic fins at the back and
while stingrays have long stingers in
most mulus species including the giant
manta rays their tails have lost their
ability to sting and sometimes people
don't realize
[Music]
this
but one of their other differences is
something you can't see unless you get
up close and personal with either of
these animals and that's their teeth
stingrays have crushing teeth plates
that help them feed on Crustaceans and
fish mobular Rays on the other hand only
have teeth on their lower jaw and these
are small peg-shaped uneven teeth pretty
useless for chewing today they're only
used for mating when males latch on to
females instead of crushing their prey
manta rays are filter feeders when
Plankton is abundant they open their
mouths and swim through it there's no
sucking in everything in their path just
travels into the large oral cavity and
passes through their Gil rakers manta
rays are like giant flying colanders
filtering out the tasty bits this
transition from grinding teeth to filter
feeding dates back to sometime before 50
million years ago in the fossil record
perhaps after the extinction of the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago when
other ocean dwelling planktivores
disappeared opening up a large
environmental Niche there was also a
geologic event called the paleocene
eosine thermal maximum about 55 million
years ago in which global temperatures
increased from 5 to 8° C leading to a
boom in Plankton growth whatever the
reason manteras became voracious
Plankton eaters and because of this
something else remarkable occurred
manta rays became Giants but how is it
that a diet of tiny Plankton pushed
these creatures to become so big
researchers have found that gigantism
isn't limited by the trophic level AKA
which type of food an animal is eating
but rather by the quality and abundance
of that food and the Animals ability to
exploit it there's a biological theory
about this concept called cop's rule it
hypothesizes that evolutionary lineages
tend to increase in size over time
because being larger improves survival
for Apex carnivores this is only true up
to a point there's not much point in
being larger than a size where you have
no enemies and can pre on anything you
want but for Plankton eaters being
bigger is almost always better being
massive gives them an increased foraging
range since greater swimming efficiency
enables traveling farther in search of
Plankton and greater energy storage Ena
traveling farther between patches of
Rich feeding grounds a larger mouth and
increased surface area also allows them
to process much more water and gather
much more Plankton and perhaps the
biggest advantage of being so large is
that you're less likely to be eaten when
manta rays are full- grown adults they
have very very few Predators really it's
only orcas there is actually a recent
Orca predation in Hawaii on a manter or
or large sharks in mosm Beque one of our
study sites uh they have a very healthy
bull shark population and like 75 to 80%
of their mantas have shark bites but
they're surviving because they're just
taking little chunks out of the back
however history has shown us that large
animals are more at risk of extinction
because large organisms are often more
vulnerable to environmental crisises due
to their need for more resources like
food as well as their long reproductive
phases organisms that reproduce in the
span of a few weeks are much more likely
to undergo rapid Evolution than
something like a mantay in which
pregnancies last a full year and females
only give birth every few years their
overall like life history strategy is
more similar to say like an elephant
than like another kind of fish because
they grow really big but they reproduce
really slowly so generally when you have
that kind of strategy you're surviving
you have higher survivorship because you
have to because you're putting basically
all your eggs in this one reproductive
basket but for the giant manay being
gigantic and eating lots of Plankton has
so far been worth the risk and for a
long time we thought shallow water
Plankton was all they were eating we'd
see them swirling around shallow Coastal
waters mouth open catching Plankton and
we thought that was the end of the story
but it turns out manta rays aren't just
inhabit T of the sunny shallows they in
fact dive deep sometimes really deep all
the way down to the ocean midnight
zone for decades scientists have
struggled to fully understand the lives
of giant manta rays because they're
simply hard to track down they're known
to travel huge distances and when
scientists are lucky enough to spot one
it's usually from a boat in shallow
water thus for a long time all the data
surrounding giant mantas came from
observations in only this environment
But as time went on some researchers had
a hunch that there was more to manta ray
Behavior than they were seeing to gain
more insight they traveled to Ecuador
where the largest number of giant manta
rays are known to congregate here they
collected small muscle samples from the
Rays as well as samples of Plankton they
wanted to find evidence in the rayed
bodies that their diet was made up of
entire L shallow water Plankton to do
this they compared the nitrogen and
carbon Isotopes in both the Plankton and
the mantay muscle tissue nitrogen
Isotopes in particular are very useful
because they can tell us about what
marine organisms have been eating
because the ratio of nitrogen increases
with each step up the food web in other
words top predators like sharks and tuna
will have a much higher nitrogen ratio
than something like Plankton which eat
algae and carbon Isotopes are are useful
in telling us the origin of food sources
for example surface Plankton and mopic
Plankton have different levels of carbon
13 what the researchers found in the
case of the giant manta rays was that
their chemical signature wasn't
correlated to surface Plankton it looked
much more like they were eating food
from the mopic a much deeper layer of
the ocean later scientists put satellite
tags on the manta rays and found that
they were diving to depths of 1,400 M
another group of researchers tagged
Manas off the coast of Peru to see what
their movements would be like throughout
the day and found that three of the Rays
Dove much deeper at night than during
the day it's possible that they stayed
closer to the surface in the daytime as
a way of warming up since they're
ectothermic meaning they can't produce
much of their own body heat and rely on
the surrounding temperature to keep them
warm but the Deep Dives aren't the only
unexpected movements these Oceanic
mantas are making it also seems like
they're moving around their habitats in
different ways than we once thought for
a long time giant ocean man rays were
believed to be Intrepid Travelers
migrating huge distances to get from one
feeding ground to another and that
probably is the case with some
manays one survey that stretched over 4
years and relied on citizen scientists
along the east coast of the US collected
more than five th000 sightings of giant
manta rays and saw them moving hundreds
of miles up and down the coast depending
on water temperature they can't make
really longdistance migrations our team
just published a paper where they
tracked a manta going a thousand
kilometers so that's a pretty
longdistance migration but maybe not
like the white shark who swam from South
Africa to Australia it's not something
crazy like that but a couple years ago a
mantay showed up in Coco Island which is
it's kind of about in the middle of the
ocean off the coast of Costa Rica but it
was a reef manay which Reef man rays are
not known to the Eastern tropical
Pacific and the closest place it could
have come from is like Hawaii which is
thousands of miles away but other
researchers looking at giant manta rays
around Mexico and Indonesia found that
the Rays didn't swim more than 150 mi
from where they first were tagged they
stuck much more closely to their own
neighborh Hood than researchers expected
they also ate a diet that was very
specific to their region so their
non-migration could be due to the
abundance of food in those particular
locations finding and studying these
more sedentary populations could open up
a new chapter in manay research and we
clearly still have a lot to learn about
them including something that seems
fundamental can these mysterious
creatures change the color of their skin
and if so how did we only just find out
about this spectacular
[Music]
ability Manas are typically described as
having one main type of coloration
called the Chevron which is a dark Navy
or black shade over most of their dorsal
side with two white triangular patches
across their head their vental side or
belly is largely white in color with
different patterns and patches of black
but when observing captive IND
individuals researchers were surprised
to see the coloration of the giant manta
rays rapidly change the skin around
their eyes mouths the inside of their
calic loes and the Chevron shapes on
their backs all rapidly lightened or
darkened when the individuals were
having intense social interactions or
just before they were fed this is
something our team is actually looking
into we were always a little bit
skeptical about it cuz we had never seen
it and just with the way we do our
research like I said it's quite
different than everyone else so we
usually are looking with the Drone and
the sky and while you can't necessarily
tell who is who based on their dorsal
coloration like usually from the Drone I
can tell like that was the first one
that was the second one that's the third
one just because they look slightly
different and I look at hundreds of
mantas all the time but one day I was
like oh this is a new Manta and we got
in and it was the same Manta from 2
hours before but it looked dramatically
different all the color changing was
reversed fairly quickly but researchers
really don't know how or why the giant
manta rays put on such a show we do know
that they have good visual abilities and
large brains so maybe the color changes
have to do with social behaviors and
this ability isn't just limited to the
giant ocean manta ray the smaller Reef
Manta has been observed to change colors
too
it's a tantalizing hint that these
mantas are more complex than we might
give them credit for another piece of
evidence that suggests the extent of
their intelligence is the mirror
self-recognition test this experiment is
generally thought to be one of the most
reliable ways to gauge an animal's
self-awareness or self-recognition for
land animals like chimpanzees it's easy
enough to put some kind of marking on
the animal that they can't see without
the aid of a mirror if they notice the
mark on themselves in the mirror and
respond to it that suggests they're
aware the image in the mirror is their
own body while researchers couldn't
easily place a marking on Manta Rays the
mantas did significantly more repetitive
movements in front of a mirror than in
control conditions their calic fin
movements also increased almost like
they were making faces at themselves
it's not quite possible to say whether
they passed the mirror test but the
results are intriguing nonetheless and
while it is difficult to quantify the
intelligence of any animal especially
the giant manay we do know that they
have the biggest brain of any fish and
in the mobula genus the telen seylon is
the largest part of the brain accounting
for 61% of the total mass this is also
the area of the brain associated with
memory learning complex social behavior
and higher sensory processing and they
don't just have like a big brain because
they're a giant animal they have a big
brain for their body size so we think
that manta rays are likely pretty
intelligent probably because they're
very social creatures and you know manyi
divers or people who've been in the
water with them you know they're always
like I get this feeling that The Mantel
was looking at me or we have experiences
when they're entangled in fishing line
and they just kind of stop swimming and
let you just remove it all and then swim
off and really they have like these
complex lives and are really intelligent
they're more similar to sometimes I say
like a dolphin than they are than to
like a normal fish there are so many
characteristics of giant manta ray that
make them unique their brains their
behavior their bodies the list goes on
but many aspects of their lifestyle also
make them increasingly vulnerable to
Extinction in 2018 the giant Mane was
listed as threatened under the US
Endangered Species Act because they feed
on Plankton they're also more likely to
ingest large quantities of microplastics
and we just don't know what that might
do to the health of animals that live
more than 40 years they're also
exceptionally vulnerable to almost every
kind of fishing and in shallow water
habitats they're often hit by boats
speeding by above them people also
falsely believe Manta Gill plates give
those who eat them health and vitality
so they're killed in huge numbers
specifically for that one single body
part
but researchers are doing their best to
understand manay behaviors in order to
protect them whether that's creating
locations that have special designations
as nurseries or monitoring their
movement from the mopic back up to
shallow Waters the more we learn the
better we're able to make sure our
activities don't interfere with theirs
and the more chances we'll have to go
out in the water and see them gliding by
as this year comes to a close I just
wanted to thank each and every one of
you for watching and allowing me and
everyone who works with me on this
channel to keep bringing you more and
more videos about the subjects we care
so much about it is literally a dream
come true your support watching sharing
and liking videos and signing up to our
sponsors keeps the channel alive and
thriving and now there's a brand new
project that I'm creating a five-part
docu game show called archaeology Quest
that I produced and starred in with my
co-writer and friend Lorraine this this
is probably the biggest project I've
ever been a part of it's a mix between
serious archaeology education and then
our absolutely ridiculous attempts to
take what we've learned about ancient
technology and put it to the test in a
series of competitions against one
another with the ultimate question who
will succeed in creating a meal using
only Paleolithic technology this will
only be available on nebula and it's
coming soon last year I know that
thousands of you signed up for what we
call the bundle deal to get access to
curiosity stream and nebula for one
price at the same time but we have a big
update for anyone who got in on that
bundle deal curiosity stream has
informed us and even included in their
latest SEC filings that they don't
intend to pay us for any bundle Revenue
in 2024 even for the accounts that still
have access if you purchased a bundle
subscription or renewed in 2023 you will
still get access to nebula until the end
of your 12-month subscription but
unfortunately going forward none of the
money will go to nebula and therefore it
won't go to the creators you likely
signed up to support we know we're not
happy about this either if you're a
bundle user and still want to support
this channel by being a nebula
subscriber in 2024 the only way to make
sure your money goes to supporting us
and nebula is by signing up directly for
bundle subscribers if you switch to a
direct nebula subscription you'll sign
up and pay today but we won't start the
clock until your bundle access expires
and for existing nebula subscribers and
new subscribers alike this holiday
season nebula is offering lifetime
memberships for $300 you'll get nebula
for as long as both you and nebula exist
this is a way for us to raise capital
for the amazing creator-owned projects
nebula is on a roll with green lighting
things like archaeology Quest the new
docu game show that I mentioned earlier
that was only possible thanks to your
support on nebula so if you sign up
using the link below you can support
this channel directly and get both
nebula and nebula classes for 40% off
annual plans a little over $2.5 per
month or you can sign up to a lifetime
plan for
$300 ensuring you get access to every
piece of content the creators on nebula
will ever make while also helping to
fund new and exciting projects and as
we're approaching the Holiday Rush it's
good to know that the lifetime plans on
nebula can be purchased as a gift for
someone else in the form of a gift card
it's the perfect gift for nebula fans
and content consumers of all types and
the only place where you'll be able to
watch archaeology Quest check out